and he won his bid
and he'll be playing against Evan sarich
wow yes Sarge bid 725 to Max's 758 so
Sarge he went low and for Magnus I mean
will he be able to punish him using the
clock as the 17th piece as James Canty
likes to say and we're looking at this
position this is very dry would this
have been your opening choice for Magnus
if you had the white piercing as a
player who was down two and a half
minutes
yeah Robert I'm just I'm just looking at
the
Magnus Carlson actually lost a bit if
I'm sorry bit 7 minutes 25 seconds shows
the black pieces Magna starts with white
gets 10 minutes on the clock for
iterizaga against Parham magsudu it is
Parham who won the bid and ituri zaga
starts with white with 10 minutes Parham
starts with eight minutes on the clock
has the draw odds but Robert again the
question comes down to is that time that
Ivan sarich bid for too low with 7
minutes 25 seconds and you were asking
about what color I would choose here I
do like White's position the control in
the center more space but again giving
draw odds that's a big big give here and
is it going to be enough to win what
Magnus is eyeing for Bishop F4 a
potential Queen D2 Bishop ate six ideas
getting the Rook into the game he starts
with first blocking out the black Bishop
on B7 so there's no Bishop F3 in those
lines yeah it does look Pleasant for
white because the Knight can't slide to
D4 at the right moment up to C6 this
bishop is under attack I think black can
try Knight E4 I'm not sure if it works
out so well but the point is you start
trying to trade pieces open up your
Bishop on the G7 Square I do think that
sarge is playing this well but I'm still
looking at the clock six minutes 21
seconds for him it's really not that
much time and white has healthy Pawn on
D5 and that's not a good Bishop on B7
it's not a happy bishop and B7 but
anytime in the game it can reroute to
the C8 H3 diagonal as well but not at
the moment he still needs to think about
his development getting that Rook from
Aid onto the game 94 as you pointed out
has been played white has also got to
find a way to keep his Rooks into into
the Central files but right now that B2
Pawn that's a little lose Robert you
defend it immediately or perhaps throw
in a rookie one targeting that Knight on
e4 first yeah rookie one's a way of
Defending by attacking something else
but Rook B1 is Max's choice and I think
that makes sense just keeping the pawn
defended a black can try and move like
Queen to F6 but this bishop just slides
back and maybe up to D4 so this position
it looks very solid but it will be about
maneuvering okay we have a pure end game
here is magazine try to flag him
and this is exactly what we were talking
about right the player with last time
you want the pieces off the board to get
closer to the draw I think Magnus has to
try to flag him that feels like the only
chance that he has if the game ends in a
draw Ivan sarit wins the match Magnus
meanwhile has got a knight on D4 but it
looks like not too many penetrating
spots for the king objectively it's a
draw Robert it's gonna come down to the
clock here
objectively yes but I actually think
even in a classical game this is still a
bit difficult for black especially now
that this Pawn is on H5 and this Knight
at the right time can reroute so the
king will come to E3 the Knight will go
to E2 if you ever take on H4 which has
happened that frees up the G3 square and
you know I haven't read too many chess
books I've admitted that before but I've
seen enough karpov games in my life to
look at this position and say you know I
feel like white really can press and win
this game oof Anderson I hope you're
doing well but this position looks like
one where he would press for a win in an
end game I actually think that Black's
in big trouble
I think and that's a situation when
White Knight gets to G3 black will have
to take a defensive setup of getting the
bishop to defend the H5 pawn and he
wants to do that via G6 but watch out
what about the C7 Pawn
but Magnus is who cares you can't attack
anything you play Bishop to B1 maybe
still Knight to B5 and yeah these pawns
are all on dark squares and will be
targeted
and he goes for Bishop B1 the idea is
that after A3 he wants to go Bishop A2
try to put pressure on C4 we see the
eval bar creeping up Robert you you're
absolutely on point that practically not
a easy position for black to defend it
might not just be about the clock with
H5 weakness and a C7 weakness the Knight
can jump around to attack both it might
actually be a lot worse for black now
yeah but what I do like for sarge is
that the bishop tends to outclass at
night when there's things happening on
both sides of the board so if this
Knight goes to B5 at some point and the
King has to go to D4 the black king may
come up the board over here the knight's
a bit slow to get back that said Knight
takes C7 98 Knight takes D6 all these
pawns are going to be in trouble and
Magnus is he just he's really just
sitting on the position
he played B3 like he just wants this
structure
well he's gonna come in with the King if
allowed he would try to trap up that
Bishop on A2 so he couldn't stay there
for too long Bishop B1 played and now
after Knight B5 black starts targeting
white screen side bonds so the Knight on
D4 is actually stuck defending that B3
Pawn right now how do you improve Magnus
looks like he's done everything right
he's got the most beautiful position
with a knight on D4 the King on E3 but
what's next
he'll eventually move his King this way
and play for B4 like he's just gonna
look at this the black king can't enter
so that means that Magnus can play like
this for 50 moves and then play B4 so
he's just gonna waste time he is doing a
perfect Armageddon strategy with no
increment don't play B4 yet don't do
see I I don't love that even if it's
good for white he could have burned more
clock in the process
and what you're pointing out there's
Knight on D4 it really stops all
activity black skin can't get to F5 the
F for Pawn controls the E5 and the G5
square but now what's next does white
also go A5 trying to get his own King
towards the C7 Pawn but Robert the more
pawns that get traded off the closer
black cats do that draw yes and you know
A5 takes the king would have to go up to
B7 and is this bishop going to be able
to stop it or is the black king gonna be
required to go back to d8 and that's oh
wow and he's still got time on the clock
he's got two minutes 51 seconds there's
no increment at all a draw means sorry
to wins the match and Magnus will not
make it to division one if sarich is
able to hold this position he's found a
key defensive resource don't go King F5
93 is a big fork in the air wow that was
a really great idea from Magnus I think
what's gonna happen is that Bishop d390
the king now has to go back and the
Knight is stuck and can't make progress
but he's wasting Sarge's time oh it's a
losing move that's a losing move and
that's it you just go King C6 and you
win the pawn yeah you're just winning
everything at five I think you win two
pawns just to one and your pawns are too
fast
and he does it King C6 he's gonna
he's gonna have a seatbon is just super
fast
and it was Meg's strategy you could tell
by the way he was playing and I asked
the question earlier would you play the
solidly when you need to win he was
playing for the clock and Sarge bid 725
so he was down two minutes 35 seconds to
start look at the clock by the way two
minutes and now 25 seconds is the lead
for Magnus so he's kept the time
Advantage the whole way through and now
he's using it because he has an
objectively winning position he knows
that and he wants to accurately put this
game away hmm
well boys and girls this is how an
Armageddon is done so Magnus there he's
calculated the line uh comes back with
that Knight to E1 will give it up for
the F Pawn meanwhile the C Pawn will
advance down the board to C6 and only
then will he go D7
all right sarich still asking questions
not allowing this plan King D4 is it
time to give up the d-pawn for the
bishop D7 does that win on the spot and
just get the king back eat up all the
king side pawns yeah here comes the
white king back to F5 and you don't even
have King E3 because Knight G2 check
forks and wins this Pawn this is game
over it means Magnus Carlson will be in
division one of the aim chess rapid
event it's the fourth leg of the
champion chess tour and well I feel for
Sorrows I mean he really put up a fight
he went on demand against Magnus Carlson
but his back is literally against the
walls proverbially against the wall he
has lost the game Magus carlsen's
through